on the horizon in this northeastern
corner of Syria the Islamic state lives
on this is a place that should trouble
governments around the world behind a
single fence in our Hall camp are people
who will rebuild their cult if they can
it was supposed to be temporary a
holding center for the women and the
children of Isis and yet it endures
squalid and insecure and no one knows
what to do with them
to go in we're told to take all
precautions we will not be welcome the
armed guards who don't want to be
identified tell us about the stabbings
and several murders we're on our way to
the camp annex where the foreigners are
held ten thousand of them throwing
stones already the makeshift Market area
is the only place the staff are
comfortable taking us in this part of
the camp where are you from it is a
chance for a few snaps conversations can
we talk to you from Australia
so what's your name yourself where are
you from Finland so much in this place
is deeply unsettling waves are met with
nothing those natural instincts of a
child they're not here
instead this a young boy asks us to
repent our sins and then and how do you
heal a mind like that the point is here
no one is even trying in our Hall
radicalized mothers are with children
who've seen no other life where are you
from I'm from these monks page
yeah but where were you from before I'm
from these lunch space have you heard
about al-baghdadi al-baghdadi no little
mafia Donatella arpaia
they are angry and yet emboldened by the
news of the death of Isis leader Abu
Bakr al Baghdadi last month has been
killed another one come and if this one
is killing another one we come you still
believe in the ideology of - yes of
course
why'd you change look how the truth the
truth is here just like just like
animals just like dogs you treated
others like animals yeah - cut people's
heads off they burn people alive no it's
not true stiffened up with n sorry ok X
is it in the end there are 70,000 people
here now it is a town not a camp
there is no school aid agencies struggle
to operate because of the security
healthcare is at its most basic the camp
authorities say that further
radicalization is taking place in the
camp all the time this is the market
area at one stage years ago it was an
existing refugee camp
now those refugees who are here who fled
Isis are mixing with the ISIS women
essentially a new mini Caliphate is
being created it's your it's your baby
you have two children
Sonya kediri from Italy was one we found
who did appear repentant do you
understand why the Italian government
would think you are a danger you don't
believe the ideology of - anymore but is
this genuine or would she be a threat
back home again no one is making the
judgement the gesture is genuinely
Islamic the oneness of God but here in
our Hall it's been warped and twisted
Isis is rising again Marc stone Sky News
in Syria